ever since russia invaded ukraine the
world has been afraid of one thing
russia's nukes
but
what exactly would happen if russian
president vladimir putin decided to push
the red button
what could lead to putin
detonating a nuclear weapon
what chain of command would this order
need to follow
and what would happen if nato's member
countries fought back
this is what if and here's what would
happen if russia launched a nuke
when the united states attacked the
japanese cities of hiroshima and
nagasaki in 1945
it marked the only two times in history
that nuclear weapons have been used
during a time of war
the destruction and casualties from
these bombs were devastating
combined an estimated
120 000 people were killed instantly
and tens of thousands more in the
following months people within one
kilometer of the detonations were
carbonized by heat rays
and those within one and a half
kilometers from ground zero suffered
flash burning and severe damage to their
skin
fast forward to today and russia has
more nukes than any other country
and putin has already ordered russia's
nuclear forces on high alert
threatening any country that sides with
ukraine
so could the world be on a razor's edge
of a nuclear winter
based on russia's policies on nuclear
deterrence
there are a few basic principles by
which putin could make the decision to
use nuclear weapons
one of the reasons for this
world-changing launch could be ballistic
missiles aimed at russia or its allies
another might be any attack on critical
government or military sites that would
undermine russia's nuclear forces
ability to respond
finally and maybe the most concerning of
reasons
is the use of conventional weapons
against russia that it perceives as a
direct threat to its existence
yeah this means that russia could launch
nukes if any member of the north
atlantic treaty organization or nato
started to directly intervene in the war
in ukraine and it's this kind of nuclear
posturing that has led to many western
leaders indicating that there's a limit
to how far they would go to help ukraine
defend against russia
now if this were to go down it would all
begin with putin and a small briefcase
that he keeps close to him at all times
this is known as the chight
and it would connect the russian
dictator to the command network of
russia's nuclear forces
putin wouldn't be just pushing a big red
button to launch
instead he would transmit launch orders
to the general staff which is his
central military command
the russian general staff would then
launch nuclear missiles by sending
authorization codes to individual
weapons
commanders or in case the command posts
were destroyed
they could bypass those by using a
backup system called perimeter
this would allow the general staff to
directly initiate the launch of
land-based missiles remotely
if they were to do that
these land-based missiles would take
about 30 minutes to reach a country like
the united states
if the launch came from a submarine
positioned closer to u.s territory it
would only take 10 to 15 minutes for the
strike to land
once launched the u.s military's
space-based infrared system would detect
any missiles with infrared radiation
within minutes president joe biden would
be alerted and a few moments later the
response would likely be an immediate
massive
counter-attack that would mean the
deployment of potentially hundreds if
not thousands of aircraft nuclear
submarines and land-based heavy
artillery vehicles armed with missiles
but even this huge military action would
still only be a reaction to the first
launch
imagine if a warhead detonated in
washington dc just a few blocks away
from the white house
even if this device was only two-thirds
as powerful as the bomb dropped on
hiroshima everything within
approximately one kilometer would be
destroyed
over 45 000 people would be killed and
another 300 000 more injured
anyone within 8 kilometers could be
temporarily blinded by the overwhelming
flash of light from the blast people as
far as 30 kilometers away from the
explosion could be enveloped in a
mixture of dust debris and deadly
byproducts of radiation
this would be a terrible preview of the
devastating effects that any further
escalation could have on the whole world
not just north america
if russia and the united states
detonated their full arsenal of nuclear
weapons the entire planet would be
covered with a blanket of soot in only
two weeks
the soot would block sunlight and could
lower the temperatures to below freezing
even in the summer months
and it could take 10 years for it to
dissipate
the threat of nuclear war is terrifying
but all may not be totally lost russia's
army was considered to be one of the
most powerful in the world but their
invasion of ukraine has revealed that
the russian army may be more
inadequately equipped and poorly trained
than expected
the looming threat of nuclear war
could just be another way for russia to
keep the world in a submissive state of
fear
putin may or may not have gone insane
he sure is unstable but he's not the
only person involved in launching nukes
besides nuclear war isn't a game
if you were the first person to launch a
nuclear strike
you'd have very likely ensured your own
death
but
what if we could use all of russia's
nuclear arsenal for something different
like terraforming mars
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you